so we've got 2017 pretty much behind us
looking ahead to 2018 what has me
excited so I like to look ahead to the
movies that are gonna be coming out in
the next calendar year figure out what
I'm excited about now I don't have a
full top ten because I make a
distinction between being excited for
something and simply being hopeful for
it there's a ton of movies that I hope
are good help any movie that I spend the
money to go and see I hope is good but
that's not the same as being genuinely
excited and pumped for it when it comes
to those I've got nine so here are the
nine movies coming out in 2018 that I
think are worth getting excited about
number 9 the predator now normally
another attempt to revive the predator
franchise would have me just shrugging
but I got two words for you about why I
care Shane Black this man is on an
absolute roll as far as I'm concerned
and like if if the weakest thing he's
done since he's really gotten out into
writing and directing lately is Iron Man
3 I still call that we're really really
solid so it's his involvement
specifically especially knowing that he
was in the original predator I'm just
really excited to see what he's gonna do
with it cuz I think he's a really smart
writer and the thing is you don't often
get smart writers dealing with the macho
insanity of something like predator you
tend to get frankly you tend to get lazy
hack writers because that's who Studios
assigned to them because they think
that's all the property is worth Shane
Black's a really smart writer and I
really want to see what he does with
this number 8 Deadpool 2 I enjoy
Deadpool quite a bit I'm not quite as
high on it as some people are but I
thought it was a lot of fun and I want
to see what else we can get out of it I
think maybe part of the reason it's not
as high for me is I'm not a big fan of
the character of cable and I'm also not
a big fan of Josh Brolin as an actor but
I have enough faith in you know Ryan
Reynolds and the creative team that have
been put behind this that they
understand how to make
character work because he is it is
possible to do him wrong he can be
grading if overplayed if you don't dose
him just right and having cable there to
be the straight man probably a good way
to balance it so I think this is gonna
be a fun raucous
obscene time at the movies and I expect
I'll get that number seven New Mutants
now at this point I feel the need to
clarify this is not a ranking of which I
think will be the best movies of 2018
this is simply a ranking of my own level
of excitement so before you go me how
could you possibly think New Mutants
will be better than Deadpool - it's not
that I think that it's just that I'm
more excited to see what it is cuz the
thing about Deadpool - is I have a
pretty good sense of what that's gonna
be New Mutants I don't know what it's
gonna be I know what the trailers are
selling me and I am super intrigued by
that could it go off the rails yeah
absolutely
this could go way off the rails but I'm
really curious to see this flat out sort
of teenage haunted Asylum horror movie
looking thing with Butte ins
I'm really curious I'm excited to see
what the results are again fully aware
of the fact that this could completely
fall apart but yeah this this is a
prospect that really excites me because
I get excited by new directions for
superhero movies cuz I think it's the
best way to keep the genre going is by
not having them all be the same and this
is really different number six
Elita battle angel now I did my review
of the first trailer out and I had a few
reservations and I still have them but
seriously I've been waiting on for this
movie for a long long time and I also
feel the need to clarify it for some
reason people saw my video talking about
the trailer and they got the impression
that I seen the OVA but not read the
manga I've read the MA I have the first
three volumes of the manga I've read
them a couple of times I'm overdue for a
reread to be blunt about it but like I
do I love this property a lot and I am
really excited to see what is gonna
happen and how it's gonna be adjusted
and I'm curious to see how James
Cameron's storytelling instincts might
temper and sort of better focus Robert
Rodriguez who can be a little bit
scattershot sometimes and the two of
them teaming on this property just
excites me this could be something
really really special if all the things
line up the way that I really hope they
do number five annihilation again two
words Alex Garland I Alex Carlin was a
guy I kept an eye on back when he was
just a writer
I thought he were really interesting
really intelligent really thoughtful
scripts and then he went and made ex
machina as in the first movie he ever
directed and God you know that that does
not look like somebody's feature film
debut as a director it has such a
unassured hand in terms of handling the
visuals and he knows how to bring the
best out of out of his own ideas from
the page so not even knowing very much
about the plot of annihilation and kind
of intentionally keeping it that way
just his name and knowing that it is him
going sci-fi again cuz I love his take
on sci-fi stuff that alone has me really
excited
number four super troopers - that might
seem like an odd pic for you but I I do
really like broken lizard in general and
I really do like the first super
troopers how much am I looking forward
to super troopers - I helped fund it I
was involved in the IndieGoGo campaign
to get the thing made I have a t-shirt
to prove it that was exclusive to
backers of them films so yeah I'm
excited for this movie and I really
wanted to be good because I kind of
already bought my ticket
it's not in the most literal sense
possible but I love the the feel of it
the approach to the humor I like the
characters and look I'm also a sucker
I'm not above pandering it's set in
Vermont I live in Vermont I know that
seems minor but they got a surprising
amount of things that just felt right
incorrect about Vermont in the way that
they he depicted all of it and I enjoyed
that before and I'm hoping to get more
of that again number three the happy
time murders this is another one that
I've been waiting for a long long time
for I remember first hearing about this
way back when they just couldn't get
funding for it and that has been a long
road so if you've never heard of the
happy
murders basically imagine Who Framed
Roger Rabbit
but instead of toons its puppets and so
it is an r-rated murder mystery in a
world that has both humans and puppets
and the puppets are kind of second-class
citizens and there's a puppet detective
and realize it is the Jim Henson company
making it this is not god this is not
gonna be like meet the Feebles where
it's kind of a cool novelty that is
puppets but you're left lying boy I wish
this was Muppet caliber puppetry going
on this is gonna be the Muppets
this is gonna be our rated Muppet level
puppetry and performance of the puppets
and that style of puppet I'm oh I'm so
excited about this I've been waiting on
this one for a long time and yes
number two Avengers infinity war it's
got a lot to live up to it's got a lot
going on it's got a lot of elements to
juggle it may not be possible for one
film to juggle this many characters and
this much build up and actually work but
damn I'm still excited to see it and I
still got chills on on the back of my
neck when I saw that first trailer and I
can't help but be excited everything in
my rational brain says dial back your
excitement keep it in check it's gonna
be almost impossible for this to live up
to the hype but my rational brain cannot
trump
my gut instinct which is just yeah I'm
super super pumped for this one it's
kind of impossible for me not to be
oddly though it's not my number one
movie that I'm most excited for although
the one I am is not far off the movie I
am most excited for going to 2018 is
Black Panther and it might seem odd to
some that I'm more excited for Black
Panther than infinity War part of that
has to do though with the fact that as
much as infinity war is going to deliver
bigger than I've probably ever seen from
a Marvel film it's also gonna be
bringing together a ton of elements that
I already know about and I mean I am
excited for that
but I get more excited about what's new
as opposed to giving me more of what I
already like just looking at the trail
for Black Panther getting a look at what
Conda getting a sense of this world in
these carriages and just getting a
feeling of I haven't seen this before I
love the aesthetic the afrofuturism look
and feel and vibe to the whole thing I'm
like this is really cool and for me and
what I have experienced in my lifetime
as in taker of entertainment this is
really new to me and it's exciting and
it's thrilling and it's in a genre I
love which is superheroes and it's a
character who I already know that I like
because I like chadwick boseman a lot
when he appeared in civil war but even
though I know him I don't know this
world he comes from I don't know these
other characters I am so excited to get
to know them and dig in and just find
out war and that is why Black Panther is
for me my most anticipated movie of 2018
so that's my list what are you most
excited for looking ahead to the next
year whatever it is drop something down
the comments let's talk about it like
subscribe follow me on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast Apple podcast and
stitcher radio I am one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that's a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire Water podcast comm
links for all the stuff is down below
and until next time as council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]